some you see
and some
you don't
but they all have eight legs
and a bundle of bulging eyeballs
this is the real nightmare on elm street
of the arachnid kind
where the freaky turn deadly tricks
and gorge themselves on grotesque liquid
diets
so best to look in that shoe
because whoever said good things come in
small packages
wasn't talking about these guys
for many people
spiders are downright terrifying
[Music]
in our heads they're monstrous killers
and always larger than life
but spiders don't have to be big
to be deadly
this little guy's got moves like a
superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
bad news for a honeybee
he's oblivious to the googly eyes sizing
him up
this is a jumping spider
and it can broad jump up to 40 times its
length
[Music]
that's like a human jumping a 250 foot
wide chasm
the length of five tractor trailers
[Music]
okay so he's cheating
but even spider-man uses a safety line
[Music]
[Applause]
the landing is right on target
thanks to some killer depth perception
[Music]
it's a breathtaking performance
especially for the bee
this is no walk in the park
especially if a certain arachnid decides
to hitch a ride
the tick
a seriously creepy blood guzzler
just another eight-legged freak
or a killer
when ticks dig in for a meal
they don't seem to know when to stop
females can swell to 100 times their
pre-feeding weight
when they sense warm blood they jab
serrated mouth parts into our flesh
[Music]
here's a quick demonstration
pretend the jello is your blood
[Music]
to hold on tight they spew a bit of
cement to solidify their attachment to
us
which is why they're so hard to remove
females feed for days
long enough for a male to fire and
mate that's right
some species use you for sex while
drinking your blood
before dropping off
[Music]
but what's worse
they almost always leave little gifts
behind
like bacteria
or viruses
tick-borne illnesses like lyme disease
can cause years of agony
and tictyphus
can actually kill a person
but there's one more killer in the
arachnid family album
the scorpion
and it's best to avoid this eight-legged
critter too
[Music]
our first is africa's death stalker
a well-deserved name
[Music]
its sting contains neurotoxic venom
three times more powerful than a cobras
within minutes blood pressure soars
fever sets in
and convulsions follow
adults survive
children
often do not
you can spot a scorpion by its tail
but steer clear of that stinger
the scorpion design was perfected over
400 million years ago
so they probably even terrorized the
dinosaurs
today about 1200 species roam the earth
and all are venomous
[Music]
25 are deadly to us
killing as many as 5 000 people a year
the death stalker haunts north africa
and the middle east
but he's not hunting humans
[Music]
when a tasty insect drops in pincers
grab dinner
[Music]
a jab of deadly venom makes it safe to
eat
[Music]
and what better way to start a meal than
with the juiciest part
the head
scorpions also live in the sonoran
desert
where you'd think they'd rule
but not with gals like this around
she's a tarantula
well matched against her eight-legged
cousin
but a beast of a different brand
slithers into the mix
[Music]
next to the tarantula the diamond back
is a heavyweight and has a venomous bite
to match
so this fight
depends on speed
[Music]
fangs down the tarantula wins
even the snakes surprised
then she does what she does best and
digs into her meaty meal
tarantulas are the largest spiders in
the world
and this
is the granddaddy of them all
named the goliath for obvious reasons
like its foot wide leg span
[Music]
it's fast enough to catch a bird
but they're a rare treat
to hunt the goliath lays out a nearly
invisible silk trip line
and waits
the mouse has no idea what he's walking
into
but the spider can feel the mouse
approach
super sensitive hairs pick up the
slightest vibration in the air or leaf
litter
and a tiny tug on the trip line
seals the deal
inch-long fangs inject neurotoxic venom
rendering the toothy victim instantly
harmless
and dead
if the tables are turned and you
threaten a goliath's life
get ready for a performance
it rears up like a horse
as if it doesn't look big enough already
then it rubs its legs against its hairy
abdomen
flinging spiky hairs into the breeze
they pierce skin like darts then burn
and itch
as a last resort
it'll sink its fangs right into your
flesh
but no worries
you won't keel over unless you're
allergic to the venom
the spider of our nightmares is
impressive for sure
but more bluff than bite
[Music]
spiders have evolved with some amazing
ways to hunt
the bolus spider
is a bit of a cowboy
it sends out a line of silk with a drop
of glue on the end
and then whips it around like a lasso
[Music]
but this line has a twist
the glue contains pheromones that
attract certain male moths
and nothing else
talk about a piggy eater
they're the only thing the bulls spider
chows on
dinner is a cinch to round up
clearly it isn't this cowboy's first
rodeo
hunters
like this european wolf spider
need big eyes
all the better to see you with
like their namesakes
wolf spiders sleep in a den and hunt on
the run
using nothing fancy
just speed
and a grab that would make any wolf
proud
the wolf spider may be quick
but he's about to meet his match
[Music]
the trapdoor spider lives in a sort of
hobbit hole
hidden by a door hinged with silk
he waits
until he sends his vibrations from above
it's the wolf spider
out hunting
but this is no hobbit
[Music]
the trapdoor spiders tactic is pretty
underhanded
but highly effective
just another way to kill
in this spider eat spider world
[Music]
this meadow may look idyllic
but it's crawling with killers
spiders decked out in camouflage and
lying in wait
[Music]
they look pretty innocent
just hanging around minding their own
business
until lunch presents itself
[Music]
the crab spider's true colors come
rushing out in a stab of venom
and with typical arachnid flare it spews
digestive juice into its victim's shell
and then
drinks its innards
nothing like a gut-flavored slurpee on a
hot day
[Music]
some hunters rely on flashier tactics
this south american tarantula is named
pinktoe
maybe because her toes are pretty pink
like she's had a pedicure
but color is not the only thing that
makes her feet special
hooks and millions of tiny hairs on the
tips of a tarantula's legs allow them to
defy
gravity so this
is an easy crime
in fact she lives most of her life in
the trees
wriggling chicks can't help but send
vibrations
so the pink toe knows exactly where they
are
[Music]
and you know exactly what comes next
a tasty snack
for the tarantula
not only do some spiders defy gravity
others like the european raft spider
can walk on water
hairs on its legs allow the spider to
stay afloat
and the water surface transmits messages
once again it's vibrations that give
prey away
when a ripple comes in the raft spider
knows exactly where to lunge
[Music]
they can even subdue a fish that to a
human would be four times the size of a
marlin
but spiders
have no interest in catch and release
[Music]
spiders on the hunt are masters of trees
and water
[Music]
so why not sand
this is africa's non-near the desert
dangerous for many reasons
including this
the six eyed sand spider
it has one of the most toxic venoms on
earth
it's barely the size of a fingernail
easy to miss
so its biggest weapon
is the element of surprise
[Music]
the six eye doesn't stalk prey
or spin webs
it buries itself in the sand
[Music]
microscopic hairlets on its back hold
the sand in place like a cloak
[Music]
you'd think it would just cook out here
but it can survive for a year without a
single meal or drop to drink
[Music]
and it's always ready to strike
a perfect meal doesn't have to be big
[Music]
a fish moth will do
the killing tool is cytotoxic venom
a cell destroyer
the six eye gets the scientific name
sarcarius or assassin
[Applause]
because scientists believe it might have
the most lethal venom in the world
to a human
one stab of it spells catastrophe
[Music]
symptoms develop slowly
first pain near the bite
then lesions develop as the tissue dies
venom courses through the bloodstream
vessels collapse
and organs fail
no antivenin exists
at best it means loss of a limb
at worst
curtains
there's only been one confirmed human
death from a sick side sand spider bite
however it happened one thing's for sure
the nominee
can be a dangerous place to play
when it comes to weapons the killer
spiders use the most ingenious
is the web
[Music]
the orb weavers are masters of them
you could even call them show-offs
spider silk is a miracle fiber
stronger than steel
yet incredibly flexible and light
a single strand of silk that circled the
earth would weigh only 12 ounces
it's the invention that allowed small
spiders
to have big appetites
[Music]
this bat is armed with highly sensitive
sonar that detects and eludes anything
in its path
anything
but the ultimate death trap
the strands of the web are 30 times
thinner than human hair
but can still snag a victim much larger
than the spider who built them
[Music]
spiders can make up to seven different
kinds of silk
each with its own dastardly purpose
pulled from spinnerets in the spider's
body
each liquid silk contains proteins that
change structure as they solidify
some spiders lace special trap threads
with beads of sticky liquid
thick ooze coats the victim
as it moves in the web
the more the prey struggles
the less likely its escape
[Music]
silk
like water transmits vibrations
these messages help spiders keep tabs on
what's happening in their webs
[Music]
this is no orb weaver masterpiece
it's the work of the black widow
a spider with a murderous reputation
later we'll see if she snares a lover
with her web but first
can she use it to fool an arachnid of a
different design
her web is undetectable to the scorpion
and right away he runs into trouble
his thrashing alerts the widow
this is no insect
but will he be her demise
[Music]
they both have deadly venom
but hers contains a protein that can
disable the scorpion's
nerves whoever gets in the first
venomous punch
wins
pincers are the scorpion's first line of
defense
he'll keep fighting until she gets them
covered
now all that's left to contain is the
scorpion's flailing stinger
only after he's all tied up can she deal
the death blow
score another victory for the spider
thanks to her quick work with silk
a web builder's evolutionary leg up on
the scorpion
[Music]
this big-eyed beauty is into high-tech
gadgets
her eyes work like night vision goggles
and her silk is a precision killing tool
she waits for prey to wander into her
strike zone
holding deathly still
then
oh
what a tangled web she weaves
[Music]
spiders have many ways to
deceive this orb weaver is busy with her
dinner
[Music]
blissfully unaware that she's about to
become someone else's
[Music]
the porsche spider elevates deception to
an art
she plays the orb weaver's web
but her target remains preoccupied
porsche's signals say i'm prey
but the orb weaver already has a
mouthful
[Music]
meanwhile
porsha moves in for the kill
[Music]
it's the ultimate deceit
using the orb weaver's masterpiece her
own web
against her
[Music]
when spiders fight spiders
things can get sticky
[Music]
these are two spitting spiders
engaged in a turf war
[Music]
the viscous glue they fire at each other
is usually aimed at prey
it wraps like silk but packs a double
punch it's laced with a powerful toxin
meant to kill
the winter cleans up by eating the loser
cannibalism
at its best
[Music]
but not all spiders fight amongst
themselves
these webs cover entire trees
the coordinated effort of a colony of
social spiders
these little guys are hunters like all
spiders
what's different here
is cooperation
a useful skill when taking down a giant
[Music]
like lions
several hold down the struggling victim
while one goes in for the kill
[Music]
there can be thousands of these tiny
hunters in a single colony
and it pays to work together
but out of thousands of species
only about 23 live socially by design
[Music]
other spiders do it under extreme
circumstances
[Music]
this is pakistan after a recent massive
flood
spiders built most of these webs to
escape rising waters
and it happened again in australia in
2012.
[Music]
when freak events strike
trust eight-legged killers to know just
what to do
[Music]
we like to think of our homes as safe
havens
free of all the dangers of the outside
world
think again
the wild wants in for the same reasons
we do
food
warmth and shelter
critters enter through cracks we don't
even notice
slits and siding
utility vents
even an open door
once inside
they act like they own the place
staking out turf to hunt and mate
usually when an unsuspecting spider gets
in our way
it's their worst nightmare not ours
but here's a nasty exception
enter
the brown recluse
true to their name they're shy retiring
spiders
the latest science shows they're more
scavengers than hunters
a first in our knowledge of spiders
but every year
they bite thousands of unsuspecting
victims in north america
[Music]
they have a distinctive marking
shaped like a violin
but you don't want to get close enough
to see it
human bites happen when we invade their
space
[Music]
their venom is cytotoxic meaning it
kills cells around the wound
an enzyme attacks the cells and eats
away at their membranes
the majority heal quickly
but some develop into necrotic lesions
and it isn't pretty
it's like acid eating your flesh from
the inside out
ulcers can persist for months
and leave deep scarring
[Music]
the brown recluse is one nasty visitor
you don't want to entertain at home
scorpions also traipse into our homes
uninvited
[Music]
why not
when there's plenty of food around
whether in india or north africa
some deadly scorpions love it hot and
dry they don't go out in the midday sun
they hide when we're most active
and that's why our lives collide
[Music]
childhood isn't so carefree with these
guys around
it can mean sudden death
and for an adult
agony
shaking out your shoes is wise if you
live in scorpion territory
responsible for this guy's pain
the fat tail scorpion
like the death stalker it's another
notorious north african
with venom like a cobras
it's responsible for at least 30 deaths
a year
so here's hoping this killer doesn't
come to a shirt or shoe near you
same goes for the black widow
she's an american vixen
with a flare for drama
her venom is said to be 15 times more
toxic than a rattlesnakes
[Music]
only the female bites humans
and you can spot her by the distinctive
red hourglass shape on her belly
like a tattoo that screams your time is
up
when she ventures inside
watch out
she looks for a quiet place to build a
web
but this is no charlotte
and she's not up for a playdate
[Music]
people rarely die from her bite
but the muscle pain and cramping can be
excruciating
it can take days to recover
one thing's for sure
you won't soon forget the bite of the
black widow
when it comes to deadly critters
australia has more than its fair share
and in walks one of the worst
happily eight legging it right into our
comfort zones
the sydney funnel web
one of the most dangerous spiders in the
world like psycho killers they stab
multiple times when threatened
[Music]
and inject weird venom
it has no impact on most mammals
but could kill a primate like us in 15
minutes
still
we are not their targets
they actually prefer the comforts of
their own home
their burrows are lined with the
funnel-shaped webs for which they're
named
[Music]
ambush hunters
they wait for insects to wander by
[Music]
the silk-lined doorway is a trap
well
that was easy
a little insect soup
on the back burner for later
female funnel webs are homebodies
but there comes a time when the guys are
compelled to wander
[Music]
it's their search for mates that brings
them into our homes
oddly enough
they have a taste for sydney's wealthier
neighborhoods
and it's just too bad if we get in the
way
their fangs are long and hard
and can even penetrate a toenail
[Applause]
the pain is excruciating
and internally
the picture is dire
heart races
muscles twitch uncontrollably
blood pressure skyrockets
then
fluid fills the lungs and results in
respiratory failure
but there is some good news
in the 1980s scientists developed funnel
web anti-venom
it saved over a hundred lives
and reigned in one of nature's deadliest
eight-legged killers
australia isn't the only hot spot for
venom
south america has a deadly arachnid with
a penchant for travel
the brazilian wandering spider
it's a nomad with no need for a burrow
or web
just looking for trouble
[Music]
this one's founded
if this guy wakes up he risks a nasty
surprise
some men when bitten get painful
erections that last for days so
scientists checked out the wanderer's
venom
and sure enough
might be including it in new medications
for erectile dysfunction
but there is little upside potential to
getting bitten
authorities claim that 10 people have
died from wanderer bites
out of about 7 000 reported
18 times more toxic than the black widow
the wanderer gets the guinness book
thumbs up as the world's deadliest
spider
although the wanderer likes its south
american digs
sometimes it travels abroad
hitching a ride on foreign shipments
like bananas
and showing up as far away as england
so the next time you have an undivided
house guest
just be happy
it's the ones with eight legs and killer
venom that you really don't want
[Music]
even after all the fangs venom and
writhing bodies
spiders have the power to shock us the
most
in the bedroom
theirs
not ours
maybe you've heard about it spiders
favor a kind of deadly love
the survivor
is almost always the gal
they're usually a giant compared to the
guy
the jumping spider
you know the one who can jump like a
superhero
he's also got moves in the bedroom
it's a dance competition of sorts
except a female jumping spider is a
killer when it comes to judging talent
[Music]
the male begins by waving his brightly
colored legs in front of her
[Music]
then he holds them up like signal flags
and prepares for the dramatic finish
[Music]
how's that for flair
the judge says
he can mate
[Music]
but this other poor soul must have two
left feet
he gets a thumbs down
and she wastes no time opting for dinner
over the dance
rejection doesn't get any worse
[Music]
to avoid a similar fate
the desert spider has a trick up his
sleeve
he's surfing the web for a female
and he's hot on her scent
[Music]
he sends her an instant message
his handle
sexy suitor
[Music]
she seems willing but to be sure
he has a secret weapon
a pheromone that works like a knockout
drug
[Music]
in a blink
she's completely helpless
just the way he wants her
he moves in with a burst of enthusiasm
only to discover
she's facing the wrong way
he scrambles to reposition her
if she wakes up she might kill him
it could be any second
when it comes to spider sex
nothing's ever easy
but he gets the job done
and runs like the wind
some male spiders like this pisaura
bring a gift for their date
[Music]
the bigger the present which is a bit of
prey wrapped nicely in silk
the longer he gets to mate
and the longer she gets to eat
the more kids that'll be his
because that gives him time to use these
petty palps the corkscrew things to put
sperm into her receptacles
[Music]
it stays here until she's good and ready
to fertilize her eggs
but wait something's wrong
the tasty gift is gone
and she wants more
he's the only food in sight
so much for gallantry
she'll leave him a shadow of his former
self
[Music]
for male tarantulas
half the battle is just finding a
potential mate
[Music]
when they do
sometimes the gals aren't very friendly
their romance is a bit like a tango
only there are 16 legs in the dance
[Music]
he pins her deadly fangs with his front
legs
and then lifts her up
and gets in position to mate
when he's done
the challenge is to exit the dance floor
without getting stabbed
[Music]
she kills scorpions
and nearly kills humans
so don't expect any special treatment
for her lover
the black widow is known as a bedroom
assassin
but does she always kill her mate
[Music]
he vibrates his abdomen
it puts her at ease
then he weaves silk around her
a bit of bondage is just a distraction
then he works quickly to deposit his
sperm
linger a second too long here
and he'll end up another statistic
[Music]
surprisingly
he escapes
but science shows that so do most black
widow males
the black widow might not earn her
reputation
but another family member a widow spider
living down under sure does
[Music]
the black widow's australian cousin the
red back
is the wife who really carries a hatchet
[Music]
and the red back male
is her willing victim
[Music]
while mating he actually performs a
somersault
putting his abdomen into her mouth
[Music]
this is more than a love bite
she feeds on him
while he mates with her
it's suicidal sex
but it works even for the guy
whoever provides dinner the parents are
better off for it
because when mom is well fed
more of their kids survive
nature's twisted way at work once again
[Music]
but after all the drama of these bedroom
encounters
spider moms are on their own
so motherhood is when a girl brings out
her best silk
[Music]
most spiders weave a thick mat of it
then deposit their eggs
and finally bundle them up
[Music]
some moms hang up the egg balls and get
out of town
candidates for spider social services
but there could be a thousand babies in
one of these balls
can you blame her for wanting to run
[Music]
at least this mom gets a gold star for
being protective
[Music]
and wolf spiders take prenatal care a
step further
[Music]
she's going to haul this baby around
with her
[Music]
not only is the silk tough it's
waterproof
[Music]
she gets her business done and even
nurtures warming her little ones in the
sun
[Music]
when the time comes she puts her fangs
to gentler use
opening her tiny pandora's box
[Music]
a spiderling's first challenge is to
climb mom's hairy legs
and hold on to her back
[Music]
they come with their own safety
restraints
strapping themselves on board with a
line of silk
her wriggling backpack organized
mom and babies head out for adventure
but as much as new spiderlings might
look like a horde of little freaks ready
to wreak havoc
they're incredibly vulnerable
and quite tasty
[Music]
it's a wonder any grow up
but maybe that's small comfort if you're
an arachnophobe
because many do survive
just how they manage to conquer the
world
seems like science fiction
after climbing to the highest height
they can find
they lift their little tummy skyward
and let out a line of silk
when conditions are right
wind grabs the line and carries the
spiderling upward
sometimes into the stratosphere
it's called ballooning
an almost fairytale beginning for an
eight-legged killer
but it's deadly efficient
they can cross oceans and continents
before long
little killers might be landing in your
backyard too
the truth is
while they might all be killers and have
the fangs and pincers
stingers and venom to prove it
out of some 40 000 spiders scorpions and
ticks in the world only a fraction can
do us any harm
unfortunately for them
arachnids are some of those creatures
that we just love to hate
[Music]
for some people
they will never be more
than eight-legged killers
[Music]
you